hi Sandra Patrick iya from South Africa
I work in in craft development using
design and in terms of innovation job
creation what we do is we look to use
design in innovative ways to make better
products with the crafters and then we
get on and sell them and through that
you can job creation so in terms of them
the welding World Economic Forum the
most exciting that for us to speak to
people who are also doing extraordinary
from terms of job creation in various
different fields and also linking and
link them to those people who are the
major power player for the world because
the end of the day they define policy
and they're the ones who will either
vest and developmental work or not so it
gives us some credible opportunity to
actually speak to them and hopefully
change their minds